ADAM SCHIFF WILL BE CHAIRMAN OF
THE INTEL COMMITTEE.
THERE WAS AN INCENTIVE FOR
REPUBLICANS TO GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER FAST YOU JUST SAW IS.
MARK STEIN JOINS US TONIGHT.
YOU HAVE WRITTEN ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT OVER THE
DECADES.
DID YOU EVER SUPPORT THEY WERE
CLEVER ENOUGH TO PROMOTE OUR OWN
BILL OF RIGHTS AGAINST US?
>> NO.
THEY DO PLAY THE LONG GAME, THE
RUSSIANS.
TO TALK UP THE SECOND
AMENDMENT -- IF I FOLLOW
SCHIFF'S ARGUMENT, THEY ARE
RUSSIANS THE TROUBLE.
THIS IS BRILLIANT.
CONGRESSMAN, HE ACCUSED OF YOU
McCARTHY TACTICS WHEN HE IS THE
ONE SAYING YOU WORKED FOR THE
KREMLIN.
THIS IS SO NUTS.
HE SAID ALSO THAT YOU ARE
ATTACKING THE RULE OF LAW.
THE REASON SOME OF US ARE UPSET
ABOUT THIS IS BECAUSE WHAT IS
GOING ON IS AN ASSAULT ON THE
RULE OF LAW.
AN AMERICAN CITIZEN WHO HASN'T
BEEN CONVICTED OF ANY CRIME AND
HAS NEVER EVEN BEEN CHARGED WITH
ONE, HAS NEVERTHELESS BEEN UNDER
UNITED STATES SURVEILLANCE ON
AND OFF FOR HALF A DECADE.
THIS GUY'S LIFE AND REPUTATION
WAS RUINED.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE OKAY WITH THAT
BECAUSE HE IS JUST THIS WEEK'S
USEFUL DISTRACTION FROM THE
RUSSIAN VCHTION.
-- INVESTIGATION.
IT REMINDS US OF AN IMPORTANT
LESSON.
THERE IS A POINT AT WHICH THERE
IS A LEGITIMATE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY AND THEN IT BECOMES
SECRET POLICE ACTIVITIES.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO THIS U.S.
CITIZEN CARTER PAGE CROSSES WELL
INTO THE LINE, I BELIEVE, OF
SECRET POLICE ACTIVITIES.
SYSTEM.
IT'S A SYSTEM YOU WANT TO
BELIEVE IN.
YOUR POPULATION NEEDS TO BELIEVE
IN FOR THE COUNTRY TO FUNCTION.
I WONDER, THOUGH, IS THIS A
DREAM WE WILL WAKE UP FROM.
20 YEARS FROM NOW REPLAYING THE
SCHIFF TAPE AND SAY THERE WAS A
CONGRESSMAN WHO ACCUSED ANYONE
WHO DISAGREED WITH HIM OF
WORKING FOR A FOREIGN POWER.
OR WILL THEY NOT RECOVER?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO THINK SO.
LIKE HOLLYWOOD GETS IT RIGHT 40
YEARS AFTERWARD THAT THE ELDERLY
TOM HANKS AND GEORGE CLOONEY
WILL BE LINING UP TO PLAY ADAM
SCHIFF IN MOVIES AND MERYL
CONGRESSMAN NUNES BROKE THE LAWS
OF CONGRESS AND SHOULD BE GOING
TO JAIL FOR IT.
AT HEART, DEMOCRATS ARE DOING
THIS BECAUSE THIS IS NOT JUST A
FEW ROGUE ELEMENTS OF THE
BUREAUCRACY.
THE 2 MOST POWERFUL FACTIONS IN
THE DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT,
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN WERE ALSO TIED
UP WITH THIS EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY INCLUDING WHATEVER HIS TITLE
ON THIS.
SUPPOSED RETIRED FROM MI-6 AT
THE AGE OF 44 AND IS DESCRIBED
IN THIS MEMO AS A LONG-TIME
ASSET OF THE FBI.
THAT'S A BREACH OF THE
INTELLIGENCE SHARING ARRANGEMENT
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES AND
BRITISH COMMONWEALTH.
THERE ARE A LOT OF VERY WEIRD,
SINISTER ASPECTS.
THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD STOP
THROWING DISTRACTIONS IN THE
PATH BY ACCUSING YOU OF BEING A
RUSSIAN AGENT.
>> Tucker: HOW DARE YOU ASK
QUESTIONS?
>> NO.
I AM A KREMLIN AGENT TOO.